let's get an update on the coronavirus
figures in the UK now we understand that
there are 319 positive cases in the UK
two thousand four hundred and sixty two
thousand twenty four thousand rather 641
negative tes so three hundred and
nineteen people have tested positive in
the UK that's up from two hundred and
seventy three at this time yesterday
let's bring in our correspondent Ashish
Joshi who is here with me Ashish a
jumper 46 a rise of 46 and what's the
clinicians and the scientists will be
looking at is when they're doing their
modelling when they're looking at the
figures rising they'll see that there's
been a bigger rise prior to this so I
think over the weekend there was a rise
of 67 and then 46 they'll be able to
make sense of the numbers and what that
actually means we know about the cases
the two in Wales today I think there's
one in on the Channel Islands and the
other key figure here are the three
patients who tested positive for
coronavirus who have died so no more
fatalities this is the number that's
issued by the Department of Health Act
of two o'clock every afternoon so we can
see a rise there of 46 more positive
cases so the numbers themselves look
like you know it's difficult to say at
the moment but they do look like they're
stabilizing what we were expecting over
the last few weeks when you listened to
the experts who had been watching
developments in Italy in China and South
Korea those figures doubling day-by-day
but certainly lead the contingency plans
put into place by the government seem to
be holding yeah and as you say looking
for patterns and looking for that
trajectory rise this isn't the highest
daily rise that we've seen but still up
to at 390 but that key figure three
patients have sadly died yeah three
patients have died the ones who all and
listen we need to stress this who were
all in that age group who were most at
risk and who all had underlying health
concerns the Department of Health and
the government the chief medical officer
they are at pains to tell us that this
is a very serious virus it will affect
lots of people
because of its transmissibility high
infection rates but the people who are
most at risk are those with underlying
health concerns who are in the higher
age groups 60 70 80 plus for the rest of
the population not so serious but of
course the danger is that you're
spreading the virus onto people who are
or parts of the community who are more
susceptible to the virus but certainly
the the figure today that the key figure
there is it's a rise of 46 but not as
high as it has been over the last couple
of days and I'm sure the government
scientists and the people who model
these numbers it's not it's not
straightforward maths it's not a
percentage and you know it's not how
many people have been tested
therefore you arrive at this figure some
very serious modeling takes place and
they'll be able to make sense of these
figures and hopefully tell us whether
they're on top of the situation and also
that contact tracing of course
yeah the contact tracing is critical
it's key and I think a lot of people who
have been looking at the situation in
Italy have said the government here has
done a very good job as soon as a
patient has been identified contact
tracing kicks in and they've been able
to isolate the people most at risk of
being infected by the one person because
if you do that then you are and you've
heard this over and over again Sara over
the last a few weeks it's the
containment phase if you can contain the
virus it can stop it spreading then you
can be pretty much on top of it and you
don't need to move as quickly as you
would have to into the delay phase so at
the moment it looks like the contained
strategy is working for the government
okay let's find out a little bit more
about the government's response now
because the Prime Minister's spokesman
has said the UK's response to the corona
virus outbreak remains in that first
containment phase and that follows an
emergency meeting in Downing Street this
morning but number 10 says it is now
accepted that kovat 19 will spread in a
significant way